metric first imperial is a youtube
minefield
if we do our videos in metric only we
get trolled by
american bros meters are for the week
and if we do our videos
in imperial units only we get trolled by
everyone else so on behalf of all
americans i'm here to tell you it's not
our fault
that we haven't fully adopted the metric
system if you want to blame someone
you got to blame pirates let's find out
why
[Music]
welcome to the y-files where smart folks
like us get together to talk nerdy
today we're trying to answer the
question why doesn't the us use the
metric system
well one reason is pirates like from
pittsburgh
no actual pirates peg legs and parrots
and eye patch pirates
yup here's what happened in 1793 the
united states was brand spanking new
and it needed standards for weights and
measures and each state was kind of
doing its own thing
new york had a dutch system other states
were using measurements based on
english units little france in there
little spain interstate commerce was a
mess
the secretary of state at this time was
thomas jefferson who spent a lot of time
in france
he was a francophile and france was in
the middle of their own revolution
and was implementing a new decimal-based
system of weights and measures
this intrigued thomas jefferson so he
said bring us some of that so french
scientist joseph dambay was dispatched
to the u.s
with two objects a one kilogram copper
weight called a grave
and a one meter scale dambay was on his
way to philadelphia when his ship hit a
storm
and blew it a little too far south he
ended up in the caribbean and you know
who's hanging out in the caribbean
in the 18th century pirates that's who
technically they weren't pirates they
were privateers what's the difference
well privateers are sanctioned by a
government and are legally allowed to
attack
and harass and even steal enemy ships oh
nice work if you can get it
it is in this case british pirateears
intercepted dambe ship
stole the metric doodads and threw him
in prison on montserrat
hoping to hold him for ransom okay he
died in prison oh no when the doodads
sold at auction tough break but why is
the run going
by the mid-1800s the us was pretty well
settled on what's called the u.s
customary system which is based on uk's
imperial system
but we kept trying in 1866 congress
authorized the use of the metric system
and supplied each state with their own
set of metric weights and measures
people didn't like it what's the problem
well the u.s system was and
some argue still is just more accessible
and relatable
a foot is about the length of your foot
and inches about the width of your thumb
it's tangible and it's been consistent
today's kilogram is not exactly the same
weight as that copper doodad back from
it's changed a little bit and in the
19th century with all the political
upheaval and turmoil around the world
metric units fluctuated a little bit and
some countries just went off the metric
system altogether
and then came back later meanwhile the
us during all that time
stayed consistent now we kept trying in
1875 the united states signed the meter
convention which was an international
treaty that created a system of metric
standards
but american industry pushed back the
illuminati
not quite powerful industrialists argued
that switching to metric
would be too expensive and that american
infrastructure would be harmed so
they resisted the illuminati still in
all measurements in the united states
were defined by this
international standard so officially in
the u.s a yard is not defined as three
feet or 36 inches
a yard is 0.9144 meters
pounds inches miles they're all defined
by their metric equivalents by the mid
20th century the world's economy was
becoming more and more globalized
and if you wanted to do business
internationally you had to do metric
the reason the uk switched in 1965
was because they wanted access to more
european markets this is the metric
symbol for
the united states was also part of this
trend and in 1971
congress recommended that the united
states go metric within 10 years
how did that work out it didn't the
metric conversion act of 1975
encouraged the use of metric but didn't
require it
so americans kept doing what they were
doing but big business in america
did see the value in going metric they
were saving millions of dollars
so big companies like xerox gm ibm ford
they all switched to metric long before
1975 and most big american companies
followed suit the american scientific
community
also saw benefits to switching
especially after nasa crashed the mars
climate orbiter
into the martian atmosphere because the
thrusters on the orbiter were being
measured
in metric newtons but ground control was
still using pounds
so that was years of work and 125
million dollars vaporized
because they didn't use metric and this
was the 70s oh this was 19.99
oh come on nasa get it together you
eggheads
now it wasn't all nasa's fault you can
also blame the engineers at lockheed
martin
illuminati will you stop with that there
is no illuminati
oh you silly simple bastard
congress tried again with the omnibus
foreign trade act in 1988
it didn't take the savings and
construction act of 1996
nope the high-end computing and
revitalization act of 2004.
[Music]
still no joy for metric millimeters and
kylo grams what metric needed in america
was a champion a forward-looking leader
who can take the country into the 21st
century
and during the 2016 presidential
campaign
a champion emerged with a bold vision
for having the united states join the
world by implementing metric
that champion was lincoln chapee oh
lincoln chafee sounds like the name of a
car is this a person
former senator former governor of rhode
island
presidential candidate lincoln chaffee
yeah doesn't ring a bell
right here's why against the advice of
his family his advisors lincoln chafee
made going metric
a core part of his presidential platform
earlier
i said let's be bold here's a bold
embrace of internationalism
let's join the rest of the world and go
metric
let me guess lincoln chafee he'll be out
of this race
in 0.2 nanoseconds
[Applause]
technically america is a metric country
all federal agencies are required to use
metric all consumer and food products
are required to have metric on the
packaging and
use metric and manufacturing so we're
getting there slowly it's just
going to take a little time inch by inch
baby
really hey it was either me or somebody
in the comment section
[Music]
thanks for hanging out with us today my
name is aj that's heckle fish
this has been the y files metric what do
you think should we keep doing both or
should we
switch the channel completely to metric
let us know in the comment section
we're working hard for you so do us a
favor hit that thumbs up
and if we haven't earned your
subscription today i promise we'll keep
making fun brainy content until we do
earn it until next time be safe
be kind and know that you are
appreciated
what are you waiting for i got none